good morning and welcome welcome to the
world leaders forum my name is dawn
cotesworth I'm Dean of the Columbia
School of International and public
affairs
Seba today's event is co-sponsored by
SEPA the Harriman Institute and the East
Central European Center our guest today
is Her Excellency Dahlia goodie bus
station president of the Republic of
Lithuania who would who will be
delivering a speech entitled austerity
versus stimulus the Lithuanian
experience welcome madam president
Columbia launched the world leaders
forum in 2003 as a university-wide
initiative to support uninhibited
dialogue on the most pressing economic
political environmental and social
questions of our time questions that
with each passing year have larger and
larger global dimensions over the past
seven years since the founding of the
forum the forum has provided an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students and faculty to hear the views
of key leaders from nearly 50 countries
representing every corner of the globe
and not only to hear them but to
question and engage them directly our
experience has confirmed the animating
principle of the world leaders forum
that only through informed dialogue
critical scholarship and a free exchange
of ideas will answers emerge to the
great challenges facing the world today
the world leaders forum thus offers
offers a unique opportunity to our
students and faculty to engage in
conversations with men and women
directly involved in meeting the major
challenges of the 21st century an
opportunity that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate in any other
city or any other University
we are grateful that heads of state and
other world leaders continue to express
a strong interest in coming here to
speak dahlia Gryboski Jim was elected
the first female president of Lithuania
on May 17th 2009 in a landslide
she won more than 68 percent of the vote
running as an independent but with
support from the country's main
Conservative Party's because she was
once an avid basketball player she has
been compared to Barack Obama until last
week that is president Gryboski gia is
one of a generation of Eastern European
leaders who reinvented themselves along
with their countries as the Soviet Union
and the Soviet bloc of Nations collapsed
and fragmented she went to college in
st. Petersburg and received her PhD in
Moscow specializing in what today would
be called public administration when
Lithuania became independent
Dalia grew basket ketchup signed up she
quickly became known for her
professionalism skill and hard work in
1996 to 99 she served as a high-ranking
diplomat at the Lithuanian Embassy in
Washington from 1999 to 2001 she served
as Deputy Minister of Finance as well as
chief negotiator with the International
Monetary Fund and the World Bank later
in 2001 she became Minister of Finance
where she remained in 2000 till 2004
when she was appointed the European
Commissioner for financial programming
and budget as Businessweek wrote at the
time rumor had it that some of the
country's top politicians had decided to
ship her off to Brussels for fear of her
growing popularity in Lithuania a fear
that it appears was well-founded
Lithuanian voters see her as an
independent forthright strong-willed and
unhesitating political leader demanding
accountability and good governance but
she inherited an economy in far worse
shape than the US GDP fell much further
than in the United States and
unemployment rates soared to nearly
double
the u.s. rate Lithuania as you know is a
small country of less than three and a
half million people its currency is
pegged to the euro it's room to maneuver
is small but Lithuanians seem to be
debating economic policy in the same
terms as in the US the title of our
presidents talk today is austerity
versus stimulus the Lithuanian
experience Madam President after such
introduction it is very difficult to
talk but I want to say in advance then
it is difficulties in any country it's
better to be ironically self-critical
why whatever I say it is a little bit of
self-criticism and irony I hope that you
understand that difficult things better
to say in human form than to be with
serious face so does how want us to try
to cooperate today and after a short
introduction I am ready to any questions
any from any sphere you liked me to ask
including thought of own about Lavinia
but relations between Europe and the
United States and other regions of the
world especially because the discussion
of 30 vis-a-vis stimulus is really
discussion of ideologies in economic
policies between the regions in the
world not only between the economists of
Nobel Prize so live in an experience
only interesting because we a member of
European Union but also because we are
small nation without open possibilities
to use monetary policies so why there
are less choice as a choice as possible
for any economic and fiscal policy for
government so the recent crisis we can
call as Lobel one and not so many
crisises we can name as global and
history says that only
1907 1908 and ii was 1929 and 35 and
only recent one 2008 8 2009 can be
called group as global crisis before
others in between are more sectarian so
recent hunger tears shows that the world
economy was already dropping three times
and synchronization of this drop was the
reason why we calling it global drop why
we can say also as now little bit joking
all these crisis has started in the
united states all three I just wonder
and giving you a rhetoric question the
fourth one where we'll start
still in us maybe not I just recently
came from China and so how this country
was developing it was it is growing not
by years it is growing by days so maybe
we will challenge another global
structure of world's economy in 10 or 20
years and maybe we will see another
regions generating troubles to all
global world will see but anyway we got
what we got and all of us all countries
in the world including events including
Europe we were trying to battle our own
battle and that's a problem we were
battling to our own battles while crisis
was global we were battling with our own
ideology while crisis was global our
reactions have been national at least
not even original and not at all global
that's again the problem so the measures
we reacted was not adequate at all why
for example in 2008 US credit losses
took about 19 or 20 percent European
Union also was dropping
erratically the well trade was shrinking
all these kind of reactions and results
we saw altogether European Union's GDP
on average dropped four percent on
average while for example in Baltic
states in Lithuania it was about fifteen
percent in comparison with a Great
Depression you remember it was - feta
and we saw the hunger people on the
streets the phenomenon of this global
crisis and this phenomenal large drop of
GDP was absolutely different and here I
am coming for one of idea to say what we
saw we saw new phenomena of crisis we
saw the crisis virtual and in real
economy it was different things the
macroeconomic figures have been showing
only real figures and open statistics
the shadow economy or gray economy was
not calculated into the macroeconomic
figures at all we as Baltic States for
example or in Europe in general the
macroeconomic figures have been quite
frightening but there was no hunger
there was no bad tensions on the streets
all shops have been full of people
shopping and everybody was on holiday
near the beach so what phenomena we are
going in then macroeconomic figures are
frightening budgets are not able to
receive revenues people have a lot of
monies to live with and in our country
for example during the crisis the
revenues for state budget was dropping
radically that debt was growing but no
even cent of private savings have been
even used people had where and how from
to live that's again phenomena we need
to look in and learn so what we see by
macro economy figures not always and now
especially with everything where we see
crisis is on virtual level with virtual
instruments on internet and not really
reflecting the real economists changes
so this we can catch or feel only we are
not direct indicators about personal
consumption savings and other indicators
which are not at all GDP and traditional
macroeconomic figures we used to have
before here's again the dimension and
impact of globalized phenomenons in
reality asking us to change our
textbooks about what that means GDP
growth do we need at all GDP figures and
what figures really reflect the economic
level of development so this crisis
posts a lot a lot of questions which
practically nobody yet can answer
especially because it was never been any
body before in such kind of mass it's
not only financial crisis it's real
economic crisis it's energy crisis its
fiscal policy crisis it's a bunch bunch
of difficult situations which became
very global and we all all member states
in all regions or the world have been
very much affected directly virtually in
real economy also why reactions probably
which we have in ideology how to react
so difference in each region also now
about these reactions I know that the
risk in especially in the United States
some dresses ways wrote on them that
one-size-fits-all I know but in economy
in politics it's not exactly the case if
we want to be fit enough and look well
we cannot use the same dress for
everything and here I am trying to make
a distinction with examples between
large nations having their own
capability and large
facilities for monetary policy and
smaller powers who do not have hard
currency or printing machine possibility
to bailout or to buy themselves and
their depth
so yeah I'm grouping countries and you
can see that for larger powers as the
United States for example or as China or
as Germany for example or mainly
European eurozone countries there are
enough possibilities to borrow to bypass
financial markets you don't need to
proof and to try to check market stress
or not you can print your own depth and
let others pay for it dominant position
and influence in world economy also
gives this leverage and of course as I
said we we we sometimes say that what
possible is for large economies it's not
possible for smaller ones and why in
Europe we had a recovery plan designed
for all European Union members but we
divided recommendations in two parts one
recommendation was for countries with a
large leverage of economic influence
with the hard currency that's a arrow
and quite easy management or possibility
ability to manage its own depth and the
smaller countries were huge this
balances with a huge depth and not
having commentary policy instruments
only fiscal ones and you imagine the
countries who not able to have monetary
policy who are pegged for example to
arrow or to other baskets no large
movement of currency that means all
balance all shocks of increase meant of
power of your currency because of you of
your peg to other currency you have no
at all possibility to devaluate and to
play with the market together and try to
help your exports and your commodities
to be more competitive that means
that no matter what ideological
discussion is for such countries in most
cases we have no my choice but just to
economize and to suppress consumption
which of course yes it's bad resulting
effect also then you overdo shrinking
consumption reducing prices social
social pace that can occur in the the
normal economic drop in general the
economy is dropping faster further plus
you have social tensions on the streets
that means any government smaller one
having not mounted policy in their hands
only fiscal one a fiscal policy that
means taxes exceptions bureaucratic
burden and anything except monetary
policy you have very limited to choice
what to do and that can be very painful
socially politically most of these
governments are losing credits and their
ratings and people are angry so that's
theoretical possibility plus street
reality altogether these governments
usually pay very very huge price of
losing collections but what they do
during these turbines turbulence times
these government's try in the concrete
reality try to manage stability
financial stability economic stability
and trying to keep countries from going
to bankrupt in Europe we got few
countries which were in difficulty and
they were not able to survive on the key
on their own it was at least three
country countries who went to IMF and
international funds to be helped and
that's really the message that economic
policy fiscal policy was not sufficient
and they have been helped of course but
this indicator showed that in this
global situation some member states some
countries
we're not able to get to survive on
their own and this was latvia romania
and now of course from difference was
bad grease but now they're managing okay
so and now we can a little bit go to the
different approach what was possible to
one is not always possible to another
but us choice of course you has had and
there is nothing to discuss too much he
had a lot of choices including the
choice of boosting the fiscal stimulus
it is a large economy it is independent
economy it is economy with the hard
currency capable to print its own money
and partly to by its own depths and as
we see now the treasury federal Federal
Reserve's partly in doing this policy
now it was possible to use huge managed
to go for spending programs tax cuts
unemployment and infrastructure spending
yes but how far already fiscal stimulus
for us cost five trillion US dollars
five trillion in total package only tax
cuts and unemployment aid about 180
billion and it's not yet probably
finally figures we can say why fiscal
measures together combined with
unlimited borrowing facility and Federal
Reserve's who are able to influence
there and use the monetary policy
instrument monitoring not only fiscal
that combination is very powerful and
very strong in the hands of government
including kill us I mean not only in US
and my main conclusion here is that a
global players are too big to for to
fail why if for example US or other big
player will fail
it's it's some kind of spillover effect
for all world's economies economies are
already very much via trade we are other
relations are very much dependent so of
course for us there was no choice but to
try to keep country on float to
stimulate to stimulate a recovery but
again discussions now about how much how
deep and for what costs and who finally
will pay for it Americans themselves
this generation next one or Europe China
or other countries and here there is no
simple answer because of dependency of
economy seen in global sphere all
mistakes and fell out of any large
economy is a burden for other economies
also so practically the mistakes which
have been done in u.s. in special
financial sector really have been put in
on the burden as burden for Europeans
for Asian countries to pay for these
mistakes also so all of us no matter
where crisis started we paying for it
one region pays more another less but
there is no free neither crisis neither
lunch as you say in u.s. so why of
course for us stimulus is important and
was necessary but how efficiently and
where these monies are going in that's
the main question is are we just bail
out Inc the bad guys or we just all we
are investing into future of sustainable
growth there's a huge question which
will be under discussion which
influenced American policies and
politics in future elections for years
to come now European choice
Europe is different that means that
ideologically the arsenal of tools to
fight financial crisis is also different
why Europe reacted with cautious
approach and main goal was to stabilize
economy and cautious stimulus cautious
not overdoing with increase Minh tough
national government's depth why the risk
packages have been more modest to
restore economy and you know you
remember that everybody was discussing
to each other and you Americans with
Europeans who needs to invest more and
the Americans have been unhappy that
Europeans are investing and giving
stimulus less Europe where now is angry
that Americans are giving too extensive
not intensive but to extensive bailouts
of an onshore sector it costs too much
its again risks with a second wave of
possible drop in economies of the world
so all regions are a little bit hostile
to each other and it's not only
discussion of ideology but it's
discussion of political reality and
political tensions and price which
politicians in in in different regions
are paying for these kind of policies so
why European approach was a more mild
more cautious because of lack study huge
resources of possible stimulus as you
has had and main goal was to ensure
stability and support Arizona members
and if it is not Arizona members to
create special facility to help and it
was done by 50 billion errors for larger
Romania and Hungary so Europe tried to
react coordinating its efforts on
European level because national level
was not sufficient but of course for
Europe is not easy
Europe is little bit slow slow how to
say slow organisation in decision-making
is more difficult to agree on decisions
together then then for us for example as
one state to decide now Europe
is already trying trying to learn its
lessons and trying to agree on European
Financial Supervisory framework as
capital requirements derivatives
liquidity account accounting standards
which still in Europe are not the same
I'm not discussing that we still
accounting and talking on different
different nations with us including so
also stronger economic governance with
fiscal discipline coordinating our
budgets all these things which four
Americans probably suffer from from
interest it's our local cuisine very
much but what I want to say at least
that Europe starts to understand that in
global situation at least we need to
coordinate originally but that's not
sufficient and we will go later to talk
that if it is a global problem
it's supposed to be global response only
regional response is not sufficient
natural at all not sufficient but Europe
is trying at least to learn and to go
ahead with the changes in their own
economic policy coordination you know
that 17 countries from 27 are in Arizona
Arizona is more strict coordinating
policies in all European Union is less
but that's well we will change very soon
some countries from soon or late again
joined the European Arizona but anyway
economic policies we trying to
coordinate in the Council of Europe or
governments and there's response at
least political one in future it will be
more concrete response to the economic
crisis Leafeon encase Lavinia had even
even less possibilities as all multics
states large and Estonia even less
because of having tried its currency to
era that means practically all monetary
policy decisions have been made in
Frankfurt Central Bank of Europe and not
only in a monetary so only physical
instruments country had only fiscal
taxes exceptions
bureaucratic restrictions legal
framework for investors all these kind
of things that's it in in the huge drop
of economy and because of small
dimensions of economy by science because
of dependence on exports in in Europe
and Russia and everywhere around was
crisis and foreign drop so practically
other measures except economies except
suppressing demand and cutting the
spendings in public sector was no choice
whatsoever but this measures has very
sensitive effects it's also already
suppressing the down falling economy
it's making tensions between society its
arising the streets rights and for
politicians is very difficult to manage
that kind of policy for a long time why
some politicians in some countries I'm
not talking about Lavinia now went to MF
and use this as a shield
so MF said that it is necessary because
they were not able to manage on their
own I said to my government we know what
we need to do we have enough current
what we need to do and we can do it on
our own we don't need anybody to dictate
us what to do and we managed so why I'm
saying as example of one small country
in European Union where no matter what
theoretical ideology we can use spend or
cut there our reality choices where you
have very limited possibility to use
different ideology and only mainly to
cut and stimulus mainly not financial
but more fiscal that's it and non one
three instruments at all but I will say
that levena was able to do a lot if we
look to the figures only in two years
Lavinia was able to cut and by twelve
percent of spending of GDP twelve in
three years
huge amount for small country we've yet
about I was saying we have about twelve
thirteen thousand USD per capita so in
such situation is really sacrificing
efforts of government we made also a
party tax reforms cut it a lot of
exceptions increased VA team that was
necessary and some structural reforms
which also cost a lot including in
social sector but that was also good
because then crisis appears you have a
chance you chance to try to clean up
clean up a lot of things including
Social Security in a sector which which
in in in this part of Europe still has
elements of very wide social security
net which comes from Soviet era where
everybody tries to have minimum in the
morale of security Social Security and
in this region already then budget and
market economy is already fully
introduced you have no much resources
and no much revenues so that means
socially you promised people a lot
you're still keeping these promises from
all system but you have no main means
and no managed to fulfill them at all so
this contradictory situation was good
enough and we used it a little bit to
clean the system to adjust to a reality
of our financial capabilities so why
structural reforms have been done also
and it was good because we were able and
the pressure of crisis to persuade
people a little bit for some changes
because in Social Security you see in
Europe in France for example only two
years increase money in pension or
retirement age what reaction so any kind
of reforms are very difficult for
politicians to fulfill in real life and
crisis here is good chance to make a
little bit more efforts and to go faster
in reforming country and of course
economic stimulus were more oriented in
the fear towards fiscal policy and but
not not financial one
why for us austerity measures have been
more difficult but this self-confidence
of government that we can manage was
very well accepted by finally not not
from beginning but finally accepted by
markets and levena now is borrowing very
successfully on quite good exchange on
quite good rates and this shows that
markets evaluated our efforts very well
of course people don't think exactly
that way because for them it was painful
and of course they wanted everything to
be easier less painful and to finish
with crisis fast but life is different
we depend very much on cycle of recovery
in Europe especially and for Lavinia now
we see very good recovery science where
experts are already growing the
economies are recovering can we expect
already this year about two percent
growth after last year's fifteen percent
fall so it's I think quite significant
jump and prove that all measures have
been painful yes but they were exactly
targeting the finance condition and
situation now can we learn at all
anything altogether it's very clear that
especially then we look to discussions
before g20 meetings or just internally
in the US or internal in in Europe or in
all discussions or tense warning between
US and China especially on on on
monetary policy so we feel again that
not much lessons have been learned
probably we are what going to fast and
easy from crisis somebody was predicting
that the crisis will be very very long l
we will drop and go on the bottom long
it looks know it probably we are already
recovering is it too fast are we willing
to be longer here maybe not of course
but what is absent what I'm myself
feeling has absence that global us
and global valence was not addressed
globally enough in coordinated manner
and again us trying to survive on its
own Europe trying on its own China doing
on its own and here we again facing that
global threats are not yet really
acknowledged as a really global and
influential we still think that we can
regionally at least or national
originally to survive through except
discussions very general ones about the
financial sector about new tools virtual
tools which have been causing these
problems we are only how does a very
soft discussing that we need to reform
IMF we need to talk about new function
so well Bank but still it's somewhere in
the year and with each month of recovery
and easier or the intentions in economy
world economy will start to diminish I
am sure that these kind of discussions
will also start to be less and less
important so again I will learning the
lessons or are we thinking that we can
allow ourselves so after such a global
drop still to go separately and not
making huge reforms examples of Europe
and examples of my countries showed
exactly that then all the ready small
small elements of recovery started to
pop in public already rejected any
further difficult attitudes or cuts in
economy everybody exactly already on
optimism that everything is recovering
and no need to change anything so I will
be willing very much that we leaders of
the world and politicians will be enough
clever to make from these troubles we
had recent two years to secure
sustainable growth for our countries and
regions and avoid such kind of
unexpected as we call an understandable
drops and and fallouts globally global
world cannot afford to often to have
global crisis if it is somewhere in the
region or national we can help but
globally nobody can help except all of
us together
so why present crisis offers a lot of
possibility and only and lessons and
here your University and your leaders of
university has perfect chance to try to
to learn as much as we can to present
opinions to the politicians here and
outside try to persuade politicians that
they still have a huge responsibility
not to go and be happy and say
everything is fine
but just to try to secure the future
sustainable growth for years to come and
not just only to use this increased
increasingly participation for their own
political ratings and that's exactly the
Academical students teachers professors
that's exactly your job not to let
politicians from the hook and to be
happy too fast and too soon so that's my
wish very much to university and to all
Academical level not allow politicians
to to use concrete today's situation but
invest for the future strategies of the
world economy to be developed for all of
our security so short introduction
thank you very much for a terrific
speech now I guess we have some sense of
why the president is so popular in her
own country despite the difficult
economic times that we face I'm Timothy
Frye the director of the Harriman
Institute and I want to thank you all
for coming and were delighted to have
today groups students from two stellar
high schools in New York City Brooklyn
International high school and Flushing
International high school and I'd like
to give students from the two schools
the opportunities to ask the first
question we'll have first hobby Li from
Brooklyn International high school and
then John Guevara from Flushing
International high school and perhaps
will allow them to ask two questions and
then we'll open up the floor for a
discussion
welcome my name is hobby Lee from Guinea
and I'm a senior in Brooklyn
International high school my question is
given the state of the economy
how have you support education
especially for immigrant student in your
country if I understand right the
education but the last spot my not
catching special you mean in in Europe
or in general in general general of
course the u.s. is a little bit
different matter and very specific
matter for immigrant students but let's
say in Europe we also have huge
challenge now of immigration in general
especially because of very open and good
social networks a lot of immigrants are
coming and Europe lacks probably as US
also lacks labor force and immigration
is absolutely necessary and if it is
students it's perfect because it's young
generation it can be receiving very huge
and good education because in in Europe
now we're losing very much educated
people they going down and we would be
eager to receive a lot of young people
who willing to study so at least and my
knowledge
in Europe and in lavinia we are very
much open to students immigrants and
they can receive the same treatment they
need
they have special what does the they can
come but of course in our society at
least its seraphic under pay you need
little bit to pay it's all the private
universities practically if not private
anyway there is some part of pay for
first post a link but we are very much
open and Europe is very much open
especially for young generation who are
coming with very good intentions and
knowledge seeking that's an approach and
I hope their image that seeing how many
different nationalities you present in
audience already I see that it is opened
very much Open University and society
for immigrant students thank you from
the international high school and the
question is has the US economy impacted
lifting Romania the most US economy
impact all on the tweeny
thanks God not so much and it's good and
bad good that we otherwise will be
collapsing more after this crisis
because our economy's not so tight at
all we do not have very large amounts of
trade between the Union and us it's more
affecting Lavinia via affection to the
European Union because we has European
Union member we feel more troubles in
the financial sector in the markets
reaction in the interest rates level
globally but not directly not directly
it's more on higher top level so from
this point of am saying thanks God
because we're less integrated
economically with the US but we receive
all bad things or received
what financial markets have been giving
as a bad times for all Europe and Baltic
states now I'd like to invite members of
the audience who would like to ask
questions of the president to come to
one of the two microphones and if I
could ask you to keep your questions
short and the sweet as possible that
would be much appreciated why don't we
start with the microphone on the right
Thank You president Perry Piscotty
could you inform us a little bit about
the successes that you had on your
recent visit to China and whether the
Chinese will have access to the
Lithuanian port that will allow them
easier access to northern European and
Baltic European markets thank you really
phenomenal if China is so fast
developing and so interesting that you
know that China is now very much eager
to invest anywhere including in Baltic
states and I was recently in Belarus
already they providing them 15 billion
credit line 15 billion so there is a lot
of possibility for and they are eager to
invest yes we discussed about
possibility of China to invest into into
deep harbor in Tripoli the risk
feasibility study finished what final
decision they will take it depends on
negotiations between China and
government Lavinia 'none but anyway we
we are sure that we will see China's
investments in Baltic region clearly in
years future and we are very much open
to it there coming without any
conditionality any political
conditionals the very very much business
and commercial oriented we think that it
is welcomed
development young Ronald Breslow a
university professor here in Columbia
you pointed to the problem with monetary
policy because your currency is tied to
the euro and that's a problem that's not
unique to your country obviously Spain
and Portugal and Italy and many other
places are having that trouble do you
think it's a mistake for so many
currencies to be tied to the euro and
therefore removing the possibility of
people changing their exchange rate as
one of the approaches to solving their
problems
yeah a little bit mixed situation Spain
and other countries they do have a wrong
they are not tied to era they using our
currency and arrow is fluctuating in the
market conditions some country says
Lavinia we do not have arrow we are in
the fixed board system without
fluctuation to arrows so we do not have
our own monetary policy but the monetary
policy of Arizona exists and all profits
are used by Arizona members 17 but not
others if we will be having let's say
not tides I'm afraid that we will be
automatically very much devaluating fast
and it can be the shock which for small
economy he has more negatives than
positives because for lunch economy you
can use current exchange rate for
increasing and improving your
competitiveness of your commodities for
exports but in 2008-2009 all markets
around Lavinia was closed nobody was
looking for our commodities and we were
not able to expect anyway all our debt
was in hard currencies people have been
borrowed in hard currencies for us the
evaluation if we will be repairing
ourselves at that in 2008/9 will be more
damaging than giving any profits plus
all our financial sector
is taken by Nordic countries I mean all
banks are from Sweden Denmark Finland
and so on so any kind of such kind of
voluntary step will be over blowing and
spill of effect to all North European
region so it was too risky to do this
and the profits will be where more Wars
than any kind of positive result in 2013
with mania we'll have the chance to
preside over the European Union how
might you use this forum to further your
ideas of regional regional economics and
what might you ask of the US at that
time especially in terms of perhaps more
stringent financial regulation
yes Leafeon is preparing as traditional
taking the chairmanship in the 2015 of
course we will be cheering the economic
European economic policies and all
policies towards other countries and us
also we do have a very good level of
cooperation with the US on the European
level now I'm saying not Lavigne and the
the summits practically twice a year and
then g20 forum a lot of forums where
Europe and the United States can
coordinate discuss the world economic
policies together of course very much
will depend on recovery how US will be
able to recover and we still our
recovery will be very slow and long or
with such effects as unemployment social
tensions as we see already here and in
Europe all these things will affect
directly necessity of discussion and
coordination between each other and as I
said still in the horizont is MFN World
Bank and other international
institutions to be coordinated to be
coordinated attitude towards financial
sector interest rate do we need some
kind of regulatory framework together or
does Europe will go along
that's all these questions will be in
the air all the time and will depend
very much how fast we will recover if we
will recover too fast and easy I'm
afraid that will be very difficult to
achieve any kind of global result of
agreements but if we still will will
face all of us some troubles I think it
will be easier to understand that we
need to make a special and financial
sector less egoistic less close and
homophobic institutions because until
now accounting interest rates policy
everything is different between Europe
and us and other regions of the world
I'm Carlos Stefan student at the School
of International and public affairs from
Spain I'm very curious to know about how
have you lived your transition from
being a member of the European
Commission in which you had an
independent role to now be in defending
the interests of your country at the
European Council level there is nothing
contradictory between being the
so-called commissioner or I was so
called to translate I can't say I wasn't
Minister of Finance of Europe and to be
lafiel president Europe is organization
where all interests need to be combined
and anything what is done on European
level is good for any country otherwise
we have it all right and any country can
block any decision so there is no
contradiction contradiction between any
decisions of European Union for future
and for the good good wellness of any
Member States so there was no problem
for me to make these decisions and still
on another now on another side of the
table I'm also making decisions for
future of Europe because I have the
voice which can block any any decision
if we think that it is contradictory to
the interests of my country and
interests of Europe in general hello
your excellency my question is what is
the main difficulty in connecting the
world countries world leaders in
addressing the issue of the global
crisis
everything everything objectively it's
differences of countries differences of
internal situations and personality
matters if you have no chemistry and you
hate your colleague around the table you
will never talk with him no I'm joking
little but but but it is true and of
course a lot and in most cases if you
look to the social pools about how much
people like hear about for forage policy
in my country at least it's 4% the rest
is only internal problems and for
example not only in the US but for
president in Europe to win elections
where constitutional and my also mainly
roles that that responsibility many lies
in in in judicial in in 400 years but
all elections are non internal affairs
nobody cares about forms of yours so
that means for politician who is going
out of his country and trying to have an
agreement between each other they always
feel by the skin was he happening at
home and this influence is very much his
position his behavior in in in relations
with other leaders but it was a joke but
it is also serious personal contacts at
most important everywhere in on any
level of life in university and between
the leaders anywhere if you can have
understanding if you can persuade that
you are trustful person if you can do a
lot a lot more as a leader then just go
on officially making speeches writing
the letters you can just go and talk eye
to eye eye to eye without your
colleagues and people who writing the
notes well you can achieve a lot of man
yes your excellency I'm a research
scientist in
engineering retiree from IBM you didn't
mention anything about defense budgets
and I was wondering if you'd like to if
you would be kind enough to comment the
extent to which our defense budget has
caused enormous fiscal crises in the
whole world and at the same time if you
could comment how much your country
spends on defense versus I'd say with
respect to GDP of your country compared
to ours for having a big mouth it
doesn't bother me
Slippery question okay of course
discussions about how much we need to
invest defense it's not just about
finances it is really about balance of
security in the world and the burden of
this security warranty on each country
separate here I want of course I don't
want to defend
huge amounts of monies to which one
another country just pulled to defense
but the minimum some some minimum of
government insecurity and balance a
special responsibility on United States
is a huge it's a lot larger than in any
country imaginable how these monies are
used it's another matter how efficiently
for securities that's that's the
elements where we can discuss and
criticize any government but that we
need to secure the world
that's undiscussables but efficiency of
using the - amounts that's another
matter and it and your question about
Olivier Nia we free and 1/2 million we
spent about 1% of GDP but for example
our presence in Afghanistan per capita
is larger than us
per capita so it depends how to compare
in absolute figures of course with small
countries small amounts but per capita
we give in
for securing Afghanistan a lot so here
very difficult to compare absolute
amounts but you write that if economies
are follow passively the industry
defense industry or military industry
and we pay for example few times more
for anything produced anything not just
techniques or guns but anything and you
supposed to buy with it with close
tenders without competition three times
more for everything what is bought for
military that's I will call state
corruption so here I want to distinguish
the amounts in general which are
absolutely necessary to fulfill the
responsibility which especially US has
and the quality of spending which of
course public can scrutinize as
everywhere in any country thank you very
much we've had a great group of
questions I think we have time for one
more if we could have a question from
the microphone on the right can you
combine all questions in one oh yeah my
name is Frank Gallup I'm a senior here
at Columbia one major criticism of the
past President of the United States
George Bush was that he wasn't as
responsive to other countries ideas
especially in terms of foreign policy
and one major expectation of Barack
Obama is that he would be more
responsive to the ideas of others so my
question is how truthful is that
perception and how responsive have both
administration's been to the ideas of
your country economically and militarily
any new president then he comes not
necessarily in u.s. but me also I was
trying also to give some new new impetus
in everything in internal policies in
reform policies and including in
international affairs and myself I was
also revising some policies of a
previous president it's normal because
time is changing everything needs to go
together with life
and all the time beyond on the check how
to say a life pace of changes the same
happened with your todays president
everything was revised everything was
roofing and new a lot of new elements
have been started to be introduced
that's normal and it's supposed to be so
you cannot have foreign policies or
internal or social or health policies
for 10 20 years the same so here are
good positive side of it but of course
it's usually a very difficult side of it
because a lot of opposition criticism
inertial political partisanship maybe
speed is not so great and fast people
want and not so patient to receive
faster results all these things of
course only will time say it was
sufficient it was enough and how speedy
was possible but without support and
patience of population and society no
leader can do anything why I just wish
your country because of difficulties
viola and the US just to try to help
President to do the job which is not for
him it's for you for your country what
he needs to do the same as me I am
asking my nation to help me to do the
job to trust and to work together so
that's only how you can do anything at
all it's not for one person to perform
or to do instead of you your country is
yours as the union is in Lithuanian
hands and nobody can do better that you
yourself so let's just wish you all
patience and support of collective
efforts to go ahead thank you very much
I'm sure we could have a much longer
discussion but now I'd like to ask the
President to make some closing remarks
if if she would like no I can take one I
can take last question well whatever
everything
one more question from the left that
will serve as concluding remarks thanks
i'm maria from belarus and very quick
question you mentioned non-political
conditionality in financial cooperation
and in my country which is the third
tear in your visit was regarded recently
as a support to the authoritarian
dictator before elections so of course I
do not think so personally but how much
do you take into account human rights
and democratization and values when you
try to promote economical support in the
region with Belarus we're facing not
only with Belarus with in some societies
we're facing a strange phenomenon what
we have not democracy as we understand
and the structure is a little bit
different and more authoritarian or
individual governing this we still feel
and see in Belarusian example and in
Asia practically in all Asian republics
in Kazakhstan and others human rights
here in our understanding of course
understanding absolutely differently
then I was talking with the president
Lukashenko for example and I was
explaining how we understand human
rights he said I'm sorry but for me
human rights and democracy is to secure
and give jobs to have no employment
everybody has food education and housing
that's my understanding of democracy and
I don't think we can argue too much but
of course the freedom of speech and
other things that's how we understand
very much differently but here we have
pluses and minuses women we tried to
close below Russia concretely ten years
from at all not communicating and not
contacting what happened nothing
opposition was not able to grow it was
weak and it is weak and population still
is openly and it will vote for for one
leader the understanding that that was a
mistake
came to Europe at least two three years
ago we starting to reopen slowly trying
to engage in dialogue and trying to not
just to push but to persuade Mother
Russia to be more open and I just
two weeks ago visited below Russia and I
think that message message that
elections need to be more open with
acceptance of other people to come from
Europe from Orsay organization from
Leafeon for example as observers are
taken of course we cannot expect
everything just overnight but engagement
and crash with the walls Berlin walls or
Chinese walls whatever how we call
between European members no matter how
different countries is better than
Israelite and try to think that in
isolation the nation can develop better
and we are in reality we is related not
below Russia we related ourselves from
Belarus we didn't help this nation to
develop now I think slowly of course we
will try to use as much as possible
openness between Europe and Mother
Russia and if any already signed the
treaty on border possibility to move via
border 50 kilometers for people who live
around the border more easily with
cheaper visas and so on so we would like
to to help Belarusian people and state
to be mopin to develop faster to see
different world and to be able to
compare but nobody nobody can impose on
nation by force any form of state only
Belarusian people can themselves decide
what they want and choose what they want
thank you very much please join me in
thanking the president for a terrific
speech today
you